[Music]
on this sunday night groundbreaking
movement on u.s gun control
senators strike a deal after recent mass
shootings to deliver literally nothing
again was just too hard to prospect to
contemplate common sense laws with
bipartisan support
security scare on parliament hill what
police were looking for as they
scrambled to search vehicles
soaring gas prices everybody is also in
the same boat the frustration canadians
feel when it's time to fill up and the
dramatic impact on summer tourism and
safer sports i've been describing it
sort of as sports owned
me too movement the multi-million dollar
plan to protect canadian athletes from
abuse
global national
reporting tonight
chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with that breakthrough
on gun reform in the u.s for the first
time in decades members of the u.s
senate have reached a bipartisan deal
lawmakers are facing huge pressure to
take action after the recent mass
shootings in buffalo and uvalde texas
jennifer johnson has our top story
tonight
with hundreds of mass shootings already
plaguing america's schools and
communities this year alone a group of
democrat and republican senators made a
surprising announcement they've agreed
on a compromise plan to try and reduce
gun violence frankly to come up short in
this moment to deliver literally nothing
again was just too hard a prospect to
contemplate the yet to be crafted bill
would expand background checks for 18 to
21 year old gun buyers both shooters in
buffalo and uvalde were 18. it would
also increase mental health and school
security funding close a gun buying
loophole in domestic violence cases and
give states incentives to pass so-called
red flag laws allowing judges to take
weapons away or stop a purchase from
someone believe dangerous
if this is a person in crisis that's not
the time that they should be going out
and purchasing a firearm and this would
put a temporary restriction on someone's
ability to do that the yeas are 223.
the house gun control bill passed last
week was much tougher but that version
had no chance of getting through the
senate where 10 republicans must join
all democrats for the bill to pass polls
show america's epidemic of gun violence
has left most people feeling unsafe this
is madness sick of all this pain and
hurt and i'm sick of the government not
doing anything gun control activists
wanted a ban on assault weapons or the
minimum age to buy one raised to 21 that
is not in the senate plan regardless
president joe biden says he'll sign it
once it gets to his desk
the senator's announcement comes one day
after americans protested from coast to
coast demanding action they included the
son of 86 year old ruth whitfield one of
10 people murdered at a buffalo grocery
store last month we decided as a family
to go public
in our grief
we thought that was the best way to seek
justice for our mother and the other
victims of this violence if the senate
bill gets through congress it will be
the most significant gun control
legislation passed by federal lawmakers
since 1994.
many believe this plan doesn't go far
enough but it is a start
jennifer johnson global news washington
and later in the newscast we'll take a
closer look at canada's gun laws and
whether they effectively protect
citizens
ottawa police and canada border security
are assessing their sources after a tip
led to a lockdown and search of vehicles
on parliament hill and its surrounding
streets ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson has the exclusive details on
what they were looking for mercedes
heavily armed police descended on
parliament hill and some surrounding
streets on saturday afternoon looking
for what police then believed was a
credible threat concerning explosives
potentially in vehicles on or around
parliament hill based on a supposedly
solid tip but now police in the capitol
are questioning the credibility of the
warning that subsequently turned up
nothing and tell global news they think
they likely received a bad tip according
to two senior security sources the
information provided to law enforcement
was detailed according to a source who
saw the notice to officers which
included names photographs and car
license plate numbers two cars were
searched and three people were
apparently detained but police found no
explosives and those individuals were
released according to multiple sources
emergency call logs obtained by global
news show that police identified one of
the vehicles they were looking for at a
busy intersection in downtown near the
hill officers had someone in custody and
a perimeter established around the
vehicle by 1 42 pm it was cleared before
3 pm
just before clearing that scene police
became aware of a second vehicle near
the supreme court which they also
surrounded and searched same outcome and
that scene was cleared just after 3 30
p.m
multiple police and national security
sources told global news the police
action was triggered by intelligence
from the canada border services agency
that was deemed credible at the time and
resulted in multiple security agencies
responding including the rcmp's terror
investigation unit there are now
questions in the national security world
about who provided the initial
information and how it was verified the
canada border services agency would not
confirm or deny their involvement to
global news saying they do not comment
on ongoing investigations ceases told
global news that they have no
information and the ottawa police have
not responded to our requests for
comment mercedes stephenson global news
calgary
one of canada's worst mass murderers
will be sentenced tomorrow overflow
courtrooms have been set up to
accommodate the number of people
expected to watch the proceedings when
toronto van attacker alec minassian
learns his fate morgan campbell gives us
a preview of what to expect did anyone
witness anything it was a senseless
attack that shook a nation and pierced
the hearts of many in toronto
very sad
is not good
monday alec manassen will be sentenced
for killing 11 people and injuring 15
others with a van in 2018
terrorizing people along busy young
streets in the city's north manassen was
found guilty of 10 counts of first
degree murder and another 16 counts of
attempted murder but his fate has been
delayed for more than a year while the
supreme court of canada heard an appeal
in the alexander bisonette case that
looked at sentencing of people convicted
of multiple murders the quebec mosque
shooter who murdered six people in 2017
was handed a life sentence with no
chance of parole for 40 years however
the supreme court recently struck that
down as the justices felt imposing
consecutive periods of parole
ineligibility was unconstitutional i
think what the canadian judiciary has
demonstrated is that canada is a is a
just
society we're not
reactionary and legal experts say those
in the body of the court can likely
expect more of the same that decision in
the quebec mosque shooter case
is certain to affect nanasian's sentence
meaning that it won't be able to be
stacked in the menacian
case still it is hoped monday's sentence
will help those who bear the scars of
that spring day in 2018. it will allow
those families not to ever return to a
normal life but to get back to something
that is
you know that is free of some of the
pain that they've had for so long now
it's been a long time morgan campbell
global news toronto
some of canada's most prominent sports
figures gathered in montreal today to
address a crisis threatening this
country's athletic excellence in the
last six months athletes from at least
five different sports have come forward
with allegations of abuse within their
own teams
now ottawa is stepping in with a new
plan to battle mistreatment but as dan
spector reports it's being met with some
skepticism former gymnast emilia klein
had olympic goals in her early teens but
the vancouver resident says her dreams
were dashed by an abusive coach you know
you're stupid you're ugly all sorts of
really terrible things to say to a child
and then just you know physical abuse as
well she's just one of an increasing
number of canadian athletes coming
forward with allegations of abuse in the
past six months athletes from sports
including gymnastics boxing and bobsled
have brought forth claims of
mistreatment against coaches and other
officials and south of the border
american gymnasts recently filed a
billion dollar claim against the fbi for
failing to stop a sexually abusive
sports doctor i've been describing it
sort of as sport's own
metoo movement
at the canadian olympic committee's
annual session in montreal the fight
against abuse was top of mind the
situation is
untenable we can't fail this in front of
some of canadian sport's most prominent
figures sports minister pascal saint ols
touted multiple government initiatives
to hold organizations accountable and
empower athletes to come forward
canada's new independent sports
integrity commissioner will be active as
of june 20th starting in 2023 if sport
organizations can't meet certain
requirements they could lose funding the
canadian olympic committee has also
pledged 10 million dollars towards
sports safety we need to make sure that
everybody
feels that they can speak out when
they're going through
difficult situations so that it can be
assessed and addressed
olympic trampoline champion rosie
mclennan is optimistic but underlined
the shattered trust of many athletes
there were a lot of ideas there were a
lot of concepts but like okay what's
next who's responsible for what action
items and who's going to be accountable
trust is the biggest issue
they don't trust the current mechanism
in place
they don't know how they're going to
trust the new mechanism in place
gymnastics canada is among the governing
bodies accused of having a toxic culture
it is facing a class action lawsuit with
dozens of gymnasts calling for an
investigation the main thing is that
everybody did their best to to
support the the victims it's easy to
have policies on paper it's much harder
to
actually enforce those policies the
feeling among client and other athletes
encouraged but skeptical
inspector global news montreal
coming up chilling arrests in idaho what
police found when they stopped a u-haul
truck near a pride event
plus back in business the russian
replacement for mcdonald's with a new
name after the fast food giant left the
country in protest
u.s authorities arrested 31 members of a
white supremacist group near an idaho
pride event they were found after
someone called in a tip yesterday packed
into the back of a u-haul truck police
found riot gear one smoke grenade shin
guards and shields inside the van as
well as the men those arrested came from
at least 11 different states only one
was from idaho the suspects have been
charged with conspiracy to riot
with the push to get sensible firearm
legislation passed in the united states
we wanted to take a closer look at
canada's gun laws according to the small
arms survey the u.s has nearly half of
the world's civilian-owned guns despite
having less than 5 percent of the
population canada has less than two
percent of global gun ownership and
while firearms are certainly less
prevalent here gun crimes are on the
rise and tonight mike troll a looks at
whether canadian laws are working
grab it with your left hand like this
guide it forward lynn coughlin is
something of a gatekeeper to own a
firearm in canada you first need her or
another safety instructor's seal of
approval sideways lock it open with the
firearm in roughly one in four
households canada is by no means an
anti-gun country and that doesn't appear
to be changing anytime soon how many
spaces do you have left this year in
your courses um
we're now june we have about eight
seats left in between october and
november now so the demand is sky high
yeah it's it's higher than we've
had for many years
since last week gun shops across the
country have reported a sudden surge in
handgun sales likely in response to bill
c-21 which looks to strengthen gun
control laws as statistics show an
increase in the use of firearms and
canadian homicides
but gun advocates bristle at the
suggestion legal gun owners are the
issue anyone that looks under they look
behind the curtain a little bit on this
whole gun control topic anyone that
takes that time will view it entirely
differently
the events in uvalde texas reignited the
gun control debate in the u.s and by
osmosis here in canada as well but lynn
coughlin argues comparing or equating
u.s and canadian gun laws is a
non-starter it's false we have a lot of
rules and regulations in place i mean
the course is mandatory you have to pass
the exam people can fail the exam and
while u.s politicians argue over the
merits of background checks they've long
been mandatory here in canada everything
is looked at criminal background mental
health as well as current and past
relationships or rather it's supposed to
be in a letter to the coalition for
firearm rights public safety canada
admitted only 10 percent of personal
references on firearm applications were
initially contacted and an unknown
number later in the process background
or reference checks are probably the
most important part of that entire
process
the most important part yet the
government's not doing it yet the
government tells us we need more laws
because what we're doing isn't working
global news asked for an explanation
from the ministry of public safety but
never received an answer
mike relay global news toronto to the
war in ukraine now where president
volodomira zolensky feels confident over
the heated battle for the eastern
donbass region
ukraine
during his nightly address silence says
ukrainian forces are defying
expectations in preventing the highly
contested region from being overrun he
also claimed russian troops have
suffered three times that of ukraine's
losses in the war much of the fighting
for the east is currently focused in
severo donetsk the key city is
reportedly now mostly under russian
control despite stiff resistance from
remaining ukrainian troops
it's not quite mcdonald's but it's
pretty close for these moscow diners the
american fast food giant pulled out of
russia but today on russia day
many branches reopened under new owners
with a new name they are now fakuzna and
tochka roughly meaning delicious that's
all
burgers and fries are still the
specialty but you won't find any big
macs or mcflurries on the menu now the
plan is to reopen all 850 stores by the
end of the summer
just ahead a better treatment for an
aggressive form of cancer so why is it
so difficult for some patients to get it
[Music]
you're watching global national
health canada has just approved a new
drug to treat a rare and aggressive form
of eye cancer but the medication is not
being offered in every province
canadians diagnosed with ocular melanoma
have very few options and as jamie
morocco reports some patients still have
to travel thousands of kilometers to
access the potentially life-saving drug
come on let's go
after four months of cancer treatment in
toronto victoria resident sue johnson is
relieved to be able to continue her
fight from b.c
coming home was
it was like being able to breathe again
the 74 year old has uveal melanoma on
average just 200 canadians are diagnosed
each year about 50 percent of those
approximately metastasize
into life-threatening
cancer johnson's spread to her liver on
compassionate grounds she was granted
access to a drug chemtrax a recent study
found patients had a survival rate of 73
percent at the year mark compared to 59
percent without treatment but the
closest facility administering the drug
edmonton closed to out-of-province
patients because of covet 19. the only
other option was in toronto at the
princess margaret cancer center
initially the drug has to be
administered as an inpatient and
toxicities can occur that need to be
managed carefully candace charles is
also receiving the immunotherapy and
says she's met patients from every
corner of the country imagine you're
diagnosed with something that's
extremely rare and there are only one or
two cancer centers in the entire country
that can treat you
it's not ideal it really needs to be
widely available to patients as cova 19
restrictions ease and hospitalization
numbers fall more options have become
available emotionally
we have this attachment to our sense of
safety and belonging
and uh
when you take that away at the same time
as
scare the hell out of
people
this has a huge emotional toll i don't
think our
medical system ever really looks at that
happy to heal while close to the
comforts of home jamie morocco global
news toronto
up next how soaring gas prices could
spoil the summer season for travelers
and tourism operators alike
[Music]
the queen has just passed a magisterial
milestone becoming the world's second
longest reigning monarch ever the 96
year old has just overtaken thailand's
king bhumibol arliade who reigned for 70
years and 126 days louis xiv of france
remains in the number one spot he
reigned for 72 years and 110 days the
queen of course just celebrated her
platinum jubilee earlier this month
celebrating 70 plus years on the throne
well you don't need to hear it from us
to know how gas prices are skyrocketing
across the country with other expenses
surging from inflation
many canadians are feeling the financial
strain and if you're hoping to catch a
break this summer it's not looking good
as julia foy shows us prices at the pump
are already spoiling vacation plans and
businesses
as summer approaches on the south
saskatchewan river the prairie lily
riverboat is preparing for business but
it won't come cheap to top up the fuel
tank was around eight or nine hundred
dollars
i'm going to be topping it up again next
week i expect it to be two thousand
dollars to fill this
fuel tank on this ship strecken says the
rising costs of fuel could cut his
customer base tourism
is based on people having a few extra
dollars that they can go on a trip that
they can go on a riverboat ride it's all
based on having that little bit of extra
income
in toronto drivers putting the brakes on
summer trips when the price per liter
hit two dollars and 11 cents that you
can't even go anywhere anymore now it's
pretty pricey this was like 100 bucks to
fill now it's like 140 150.
energy watchers say get used to it i
think this is the new normal
there are days when it may go a little
higher there are days when it might drop
a little bit but
i sense that
demand is still very strong stateside
there is a shortage
of supply
in terms of
being able to provide an adequate
provision to the economy some provinces
including ontario are giving consumers a
break at the pump starting canada day by
cutting fuel taxes
others are still asking for a break i
think they're outrageous i think i think
the government should be taking some of
the taxes off people are hurting you
know
something has to be done in b.c with the
highest gas prices in the country the
numbers aren't dropping i draw a hybrid
so some are moving to hybrid or electric
cars it's helped me a lot i feel
600 less
so whether you plan to travel on a bc
ferry or the prairie lily riverboat
expect to pay a little more to play this
summer
julia foy global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm chris galas thanks for
watching tonight's your canada is the
lachine canal in the center of montreal
we love seeing your canada so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks a lot again
for watching donna's back tomorrow
[Music]